salut à vous les membres de la team
menthe à l'eau avec un os je change tout
ce que j'avais prévu aujourd'hui pour
faire une nouvelle vidéo j'ai même pas
eu le temps de mettre un t-shirt sympa
et tout pour vous parler d'un clash que
j'ai subie hier sortes vont découvrir ce
que j'ai pu lire sur twitter et sur
facebook
très sympathique ça provient de la
chaîne des colloques la chaîne des
colloques je me suis abonné à cette
chaîne je crois au mois de janvier ou
février on avait discuté ensemble on
avait même des projets ensemble est
assez vrai qu'après j'ai pas répondu
donc ils m'ont accusé d'avoir pris la
grosse tête ces derniers mois bref je
pense qu'ils cherchent à se venger et je
trouvais pas ça très cool les mecs
puisque à la base moi j'avais décidé un
jour de parler de votre chaîne parce que
j'aime bien vos clips et vous avec ce
que vous avez dit je vous avoue que ça
passe l'envi alors oui j'ai répondu de
manière un petit peu agressive mais en
même temps c'était normal que je me
défende
alors maintenant je vais vous dire
quelque chose et ça vous pourrez pas le
censurer comme ça alors on a pris le
contrôle de taschen lolicats c'est nous
qui tenons les rênes et on va semer la
zizanie
comment
2 tu c'est leur choix
12 ans tu me
je
tiens
pour richard
oui
c'est mal
et votre chaîne youtube est le regard
de la chanson
pas
sur la chemise abonnés
sa devise en
vos logiciels
si le retour
vos vidéos
nafa les
décollage maurice temps carton arrêté
you tube aller sa tête
l'école
on n'a qu'un seul
c'est vrai
on chantait
ok j'ai un truc qui va nous départager
les mecs on va faire une partie de
chifoumi en deux manches gagnantes
j'y tiens on a eu tous les colloques
toulouse
minutes chanter on passe père moraliser
et
bon d'accord vous en avez pensé quoi
oui je me cache parce que ça fait très
bizarre de me voir chanter alors
contrairement à eux je suis pas chanteur
je suis pas musicien c'était vraiment un
délire qu'on avait avec eux depuis mois
de février on l'a enfin fait j'espère
que ça vous a fait marrer un sapin la
prétention à devenir le type du siècle
mais juste à vous faire marrer nous on a
kiffé faire ça c'était drôle et c'est
définitif
je sais vraiment pas chanter pourtant
ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont pu pour
m'aider je vous invite vraiment aller
voir ce qu'ils font sur leur chaîne
et si ça vous plaît évidemment à vous
abonner j'espère vraiment que ça va leur
donner un coup de main parce qu'il le
mérite
je kiffe samoa depuis je vous dis
janvier ou février je m'étais abonné je
suis ça et j'étais ravi il ya quelques
semaines de pouvoir aller tourner ça
avec évidemment avant de partir je me
suis fait un petit plaisir je les ai
mentaliser et je mets pas la vidéo sur
ma chaîne je l'aurais redonner les
rushes et c'est eux qui vont mettre la
vidéo sur leurs propres chaînes donc en
allant découvrir les autres chansons et
les autres clips vous allez surtout
pouvoir me voir les mentalités en même
temps
voilà je pense par faire un clip un jour
sur cette chaîne c'était un trip on l'a
fait et je tenais vraiment à les
remercier et les féliciter pour ça ils
ont été hyper patients durant deux jours
avec moi si vous avez aimé ça si ça vous
a fait rire vous pouvez mettre un petit
pouce en l'air vraiment que si ça vous a
plu et vous pouvez également de lire
tous les commentaires ce que vous n'avez
français gérer lire ça ce soir et demain
pour me délecter de vos petits avis
abonnez-vous à la chaîne des colloques
et aussi abonnez-vous à la mienne avant
de partir si ce n'est pas déjà fait un
rendez vous demain à 17 heures ciao